Bernie Madoff the greatest Ponzi schemer
ever he was operating for decades
decades decades and it was only until
2008 the financial collapse and there
was Bank runs people needed money did
finally his Ponzi team get exposed so
meaning if crypto would have kept going
and going and going could it possibly
have been decades before Sam begman
freed and FDX Works no because they were
too Reckless I mean Madoff was extremely
buttoned down controlled
right a very deliberate and actually in
the greater scheme of things
conservative for you know Madoff didn't
put his name on a stadium he didn't
Splash it did Madoff give a billion
dollars to politicians did Madoff ever
put an impressively saying I'm going to
give what happens when a person with no
money 24 months ago puts out a press
release saying I'm going to give a
billion dollars to the Democrats in the
next two years good point you don't
think head down wasn't looking for
headlines but SPF was searching for
headlines but if you listen to people
that talk about how they came into
Nassau you know guns are blazing he came
in he bought every piece of real estate
you know they said well you know here's
this Penthouse they want 40 offer them
32 so it doesn't matter surrounding
error give them 36 or get whatever he
was just splashing money around like it
was free but Michael you're in the
crypto world right Pat and I are I mean
maybe we own some Bitcoin ethereum yeah
but I feel like
and rightfully so there's a lot of
Monday morning quartering back about
Sam begman Freedom FTX well it turns out
illegal turns out this were their
stories circulating a year ago two years
ago
during all the fraud not the aftermath
look the stuff the stuff in the domain a
year ago was
Sam makes 10 million a week at Alameda
Alameda is a money machine that
generates 10 million a week or 500
million a year and that's his cash cow
and and the exchange is just the
exchange and and then people couldn't
quite figure out the rest except for the
fact that obvious you know all these
tokens are air tokens that are being
manipulated offshore right so so the the
belief was they were good Traders and
they were manipulating air tokens and
running an unregulated exchange
the truth of course that comes out now
is they weren't good Traders they were
goofballs and really the the machine
that made this all work
the Brilliance of it is to generate 10
billion dollars worth of fake collateral
and then borrow 10 billion dollars
that's crazy to me well I mean three
things I generate 10 billion in fake
collateral I take 10 billion of money
out of my bank from my real customers I
show fake fraudulent accounting
statements to investors and get them to
give me billions more
and then I pledge the token collateral
to other crypto hedge funds and get them
to give me billions of loans so so you
could say that last part that was you
know was I I took advantage of some
other crypto Bros that were also a bit a
bit uh what is it uh
risk addicted like uh you know too
aggressive and I took advantage of
venture capitalists that threw caution
of the wind that weren't paying
attention
but and the first part is you know I
attracted all those billions by just
telling people I'll give them extreme
leverage and let them trade these tokens
and make it cheap
and then I I again there are these
diabolical twists where Sam would uh he
would like buy block fi and then and
then pressure them to put their assets
on his exchange and so a lot or he
bought a lot of things and when he
bought the things he would pressure the
people
to put their assets into on his exchange
or trade with him so
I'm issuing Equity like the equity in
FTX you know was worth I mean Sam would
say oh it's a 32 billion dollar
valuation you remember reading that and
Forbes and Fortune okay I've got a 32
billion dollar company I'm going to give
you a billion dollars worth of ft x
equity and then I've got my shadow
Equity eight ten billion dollars worth
of ftt at one point ftt was worth 15
billion dollars so so they generated
these two Equity tokens the people that
are based on what uh opaque financials
that are fraudulent right if I if I have
fraudulent financials and I I crank up
the two Equity tokens then I can use
them to do Acquisitions you're rolling
the entire thing forward
so I it was
I guess my point here is
if you're doing that and you're
extracting five billion dollars of real
cash and then your body you put a
billion into a Bitcoin miner he put a
billion into marketing he bought a
billion worth of other stuff if you're
actually extracting real cash you're
burning the candle at both ends
and so it was destined to blow up
because they were just too aggressive
just like with Terra Luna you know Terra
UST was a stable coin when it was a
couple billion dollars and Luna was a
few billion more
it's like a six eight billion dollar
unstable thing but what blew it up was
when do Quan decided he wanted to offer
20 yield on UST and he took that two
billion dollar stable coin to be worth
almost 20 billion now you've got 20
billion dollars and then Luna became
worth 60 billion or 50 billion so you've
got like this 65 70 billion dollar
complex getting big too fast
it's like I borrowed if I borrowed 20
billion dollars and I agreed to pay you
20 interest
I have to come up with four billion
dollars a year in real cash to roll that
forward and if I'm printing my own
Equity token to pay the 4 billion
eventually that Equity token crashes
because it gets diluted in the market
the entire thing just goes to zero so
going fast
on a Ponzi scheme cause it to blow up
Bernie Madoff went slow
and that's why he was able to roll and
and he didn't you know he didn't uh wave
a red flag
at the bowl right I mean Sam was was
going hard he was basically attacking
the entire Bitcoin Community by by under
supporting all this ESG BS about using
electricity he was also attacking the
other crypto exchanges like binance he
was also going head-to-head with the SEC
those are three powerful sets of enemies
you know while you're going 180 miles an
hour do you think he knew he was going
to get caught at some point no I think
he was I really you think he's doing all
this illegal stuff you use the 14 year
old kid who's told the parents car
analogy with the drugs and the gun in
the back he's doing all this he's
defrauding people investors consumers
he's doing all this stuff all this
illegal stuff with Bahamas yeah Left
Right illegal illegal and you generally
think he didn't think he would ever get
caught he's delusional no regret I'd say
he's delusion like a week after he blew
the entire thing up he was thinking he
could just make a phone call and raise
10 billion dollars in order to save it
I he's going to process this for the
next two three four years and you know
many years from now he'll he may look
back if he's honest with himself and
figure out what he did I I think he's
just deluding himself so with all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got him in white we got
them in Black we got them in red our
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people wore it in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hats
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody saying future looks
spread toward your future looks bright
hat click over here and to watch the
entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]